the hate they give that's the focus of
tonight's angle
i think what annoys me most about white
people is when they pretend like they're
the victim
what's also annoying is when they you
know when they kill us what is fragile
about whiteness when everything has been
constructed around it
now this is what showtime thinks we all
need after two years of suffering
through covid more divisive racial hate
mongering
its new docus series called everything
is going to be all white clever features
some of the biggest names in the racial
industrial complex
so the point i think is to remind
everyone that even as we emerge from
covid america has not emerged from her
racist past
one of the definitions of american
whiteness is
ignorance
white people we are not your problem
you are should white people today feel
any responsibility for slavery
[Music]
hell yeah symbols and monuments these
are mementos of racism bring that statue
back
it's about obliterating systemic and
institutionalized racism
so is this what self-righteous liberals
mean when they wear those goofy stronger
together t-shirts
do we build back better by tearing down
our history
or do we obliterate racism with
blatantly racist appeals
when you have an overwhelmingly white
teaching force
right we have a very racially
homogeneous teaching force you
inevitably have the reproduction and the
dissemination of racism and white
supremacy schools are just incredibly um
efficient at reproducing racial
inequality
now
lord only knows how many of our public
schools have bought into this new racial
spoils system which is often guided by
very handsomely paid diversity
consultants
now their lesson plans encourage racial
introspection racial thought at all
times not just in history but in math
grammar and look they want you to
believe that racism is everywhere in the
schools in society it's lurking in the
science labs near the bunsen burners and
embedded in algebra equations as well
solve for x
sounds like coded bigotry to me
now to the left racism is so pervasive
it's even in the air we breathe
my residents are in some of the most
polluted zip codes in the nation many of
them are dying at a higher rate of covet
because of the environmental racism the
toxic legacy of environmental racism
that has plagued our nation for far too
long
now showtime i guess hopes that their
audience is growing and thinks that
maybe all those students who sat through
those seminars who listen to the squad
do their ally ship and anti-racism
courses
that they'll have shame and remorse
drilled into them for the things that
happened long before they were even born
but i think they're running into a brick
wall of common sense especially among
young minorities
biden's favorability among black voters
dropped 10 points through 2021
according to the recent figures from
democrat pollsters and it's even worse
among black americans under the age of
35 their support for biden fell 25
points
by the end of last year
i think most sensibly sensible people
out there know that the american dream
it's still out there for people of all
races
most of us know the game that's being
played here the race card is not the
only one of the left's go-to weapons of
choice against an america they've grown
to despise but it's also a tool of
distraction from their myriad policy
failures
the fact is for decades now democrats
have spectacularly failed failed the
very people they claim to be helping
with all this racial hectoring
the demands for reparations their moves
to remake school curricula and of course
remake the workplace culture
only breed more resentment and division
so you must never apologize to those who
play with racial accelerants
the nfl gets sued for supposedly racist
hiring practices and they rushed to meet
with al sharpton of all people one of
the most corrosive forces on the planet
sharpton's now moved from defund the
police to defund the nfl
i told goodell yes we march out in front
of stadiums but that's not where uh
we're going this time we're going into
these city councils and board of our
aldermans to have people make motions
that we will withdraw public funds until
there's diversity they understand being
hauled in front of a city council and
saying where's your diversity
so they're remaking city councils
you get it
diversity through extortion well he
knows that game well really it's just
what
the reverend is demanding what he's
demanding there is just more over racism
but given the choice between standing
out for an american institution and
caving to the money-hungry race arsonist
roger goodell he picked the ladder
what we want to try to see is the
outcomes right we want to see
blackhead coaches in the nfl and coaches
of
people of color
and eventually gender if there are
policies that
we need to modify we're going to do that
and we will absolutely do
hey roger
here's some advice
giving in now will only encourage them
to demand more that's what they do
the radical left can never be satiated
and since their poles are in the gutter
they're going to resort to even more
outlandish race-baiting
and no amount of apologies or donations
will ever be enough it never is
heck even after joe rogan apologized for
racially insensitive past remarks the
vultures still swept in for more talons
of flesh
the cultural marxists getting rich off
crying racism they don't care what you
said or what you did ten years ago five
years ago 30 years ago
they just want more money and they want
more power
a fat book contract maybe a lucrative
visiting professorship
and a lifetime job guarantee anywhere
they go
because if you ever fire or discipline
them
naturally they're going to scream racism
this atmosphere of eggshell walking and
non-stop racial recriminations drives
people to their individual corners
it breeds distrust
it separates us
but then again that's the whole point
isn't it
the left doesn't want us to get closer
to each other
they only thrive when we're at each
other's throats
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else